بالاعلان عن انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي في
كاليفورنيا الجمعه مباشره شاهدنا عملاء
ويقفون خارج شرعي في شارع سانتيا الشهير
في سيليكون ذلك البرد والامطار معظم
العملاء من مؤسسيه الشركات الصغيره
والماشيه هذا المشهد ليس امريكيا فقط بل
يصل تاثيره للعالم كون فروع البنك منتشره
في الصين والمانيا والهند والسويد
والمانيا للمره الاخيره يفتح بنك اس بي بي
ابوابه اليوم الاثنين حتى يتمكن اصحاب
الودائع المؤمن عليها من الحصول على
اموالهم بحد اقصى 250 الف دولار امريكي
وطبعا الضربه عندما تصيب مؤسسه كبيره تؤثر
على الصغار في مجالها التحذيرات تاتي ايضا
من ان الازمه قد تؤدي الى هجوم المودعين
لسحب امواله من البنوك الصغيره ما يؤدي
الى افلا
تتوالى التحذيرات من تبعات انهيار بنك
وادي السيليكون الذي تعتمد عليه الشركات
الناشئه واغلبها في قطاع البيولوجيا
الحيويه جاءت ابرز التحذيرات قوه باحتمال
حدوث تسريح جماعيه للموظفين في هذه
الشركات التي تعتمد على البنك المنهار
الاصوات كلها تنادي الحكومات بدعم البنك
وتناشد لشراء ديون مجموعه اس في بي
ومحاوله تقليل فرص انتشار الذعر وبالتالي
حصرها سينقذ مستقبل الشركات الشابه
الناشئه جيل كامل سينهار منها ذلك لان
التبعات انهيار بنك وادي السيليكون امتدت
الى بنوك اخرى في الولايات المتحده
وخارجها فهو يعمل في بريطانيا والدنمارك
وكندا والصين والمانيا والهند والسويد
وغيرها ما تسبب في خساره 100 مليار دولار
من عائدات الاسهم محليا واستنزاف 50 مليار
دولار من قيمه البنوك الاوروبيه
على مدار اليومين الماضيين وفقا لحسابات
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا الصحفيه في قسم اقتصاد سمر
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك صباح الخير ما الذي
حصل لبنك السيليكون فالي ليصل الى حافه
الانهيار المشكله يعني
ما يقدرون يوصلون الى ودائعهم بحد اقصى
250 الف دولار لا الف دولار اليوم الصبح
احتوى المشكله ما قال الاليه اللي حيحتوي
فيها المشكله بس قال اليوم الاثنين الكل
يقدر يصل الى ودائعهم مهما كانت قيمه هذه
الوديعه
والحد الاقصى 250 الف
مش حسب التامينات ايش قد ما عندك وديعه
تقدرين توصلي لها اليوم ان شاء الله حل
المشكله الفيدرالي ما هي الاليه لا نعلم
بعد ننتظر الاجتماع اليوم بس مو التاكس مو
الدافئ ضرائب لن يتحملوا هذه التكلفه بس
القسم من التكلفه حيتحملها الشير هولدرز
او المساهمين في البنك ومن الطبيعي طبعا
هو هذا بنك مختص باقراض معاملات شركات
التكنولوجيا الناشئه هذه شركات اصلا تحمل
مخاطره احنا نقول راس المال المغامر اصلا
فيها مغامره فمن الطبيعه تصير مشاكل بمثل
هذه البنوك كان بالبدايه متخوفين انه ممكن
تصير المشكله اكبر بس الحكومه الامريكيه
او البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي المركزي
احتوى هذه المشكله حتى الان يعني بنقدر
نقول انه المساله مضبوطه لن تتاثر البنوك
الاخرى يعني لما بنحكي عن بنك مثل سيليكون
فالي وصار فيهم هيارات وتداعيات شو خلل
البنوك الصغيره والتي تتبع عالميا مثلا
الان بالنسبه كانوا متخوفين هو بالذات على
البنوك الصغيره مثلا البارحه انيس انسي
ساويرس عنده هوايه استثمارات بشركات ناشئه
سحبوا اموالهم من البنوك الصغيره واودعوها
بالبنوك الكبيره لانه صار حاله من البانيك
الهلع بس بنفس الوقت هذا البنك لا يخضع لي
القوانين التي تخضع اليها البنوك العاديه
مثل البنوك الكبر البنوك الكبرى بعد
الازمه العالميه في 2008 مثل ما نقول
نقرصه وشويه الحكومات فحطت عليها اكثر
شروط يعني اصعب على مساله الاقراض هذه
البنوك اللي مختصه بالشركات الناشئه او
البنوك الاخرى اللي بنكين الاخرين اللي تم
اغلاقهم هم مختصين بالبيتكوينز وليست بنوك
كبرى عاديه فيقال انه او من المتوقع انه
يتم احتواء هذا الاثر ولن يكون هناك اثر
على بنوك اخرى او انه ان شاء الله ما
يتسبب
هذه الازمه في سيليكون فاني ستكون مقتصره
على البنك في حد ذاته
اخرى مخاوف المذيعين من البنوك بشكل عام
لا ان شاء الله ما راح نوصل لهاي المرحله
بانتظار المزيد من المعلومات من البنك
الفيدرالي اليوم ان شاء الله كمان ما يكون
لها تاثير هناك بعض الانكشاف او بعض
البنوك في المنطقه والشركات الناشئه طبعا
لديها ودائع في هذا البنك كنا انه هذا قد
يؤثر على المنطقه بس اليوم بعد ما صار
لانه سيتم احتواء ايضا يقدم الفيدرالي
اليوم قال انه سيقدم قروض للبنوك الاخرى
بشروط ميسره لمده سنه هذه طبعا كلها جاءت
تداعيات نتيجه بصوره سريعه خلال السنه هل
يمكن ان يشتري ايلون ماسك بنك سيليكون ذلك
كما هو متداول وبعد بعد
خلص والله ما اعرف
ننتظر ما نعرف هو يطلع منه كل شيء يعني
على كل حال الحديث يتم في هذا الخصوص ونحن
نشكرك جزيل الشكر لكن انتهى وقت البرنامج
شكرا جزيلا لك سمر المشطه شكرا لك يا سمر
شكرا